my fate and fabled co-host Dr Boya mcer
recently challenged me to choose my
favorite Aztec god from the more than
200 Gods to pick from that's not an easy
choice but my top total or Aztec God
would have to be echel a goddess of both
destruction and creation she is Jaguar
ears wears a serpent as a headdress and
sometimes a pattern of crossed Bones on
her skirt which is pretty rad she's
associated with floods in storms as well
as Midwifery weaving divination and
medicine as someone who comes from three
generations of physician and scientists
I'm a fan of her overarching role as
guardian between the thin line of life
and death we all know the human body is
wildly complex I'll take all the
protection I can get who's your top
total